times accused of promoting cancel
culture by highlighting how a young man
got his revenge on a former classmate
eighteen-year-old mimi groves was forced
to withdraw from college after a year's
old clip
of her using a racial slur resurfaced
here's the back story
in 2016 groves recorded a three second
video using the slur
which she has since apologized for three
years later her classmate jimmy
galligan who comes from a mixed race
family was sent the clip
he then waited until groves chose her
college to post the video in the days
after george floyd's death
that of course set off a firestorm but
gallaghan
doesn't regret it and he said this i
wanted to get her
where she would understand the severity
of that word
if i never posted that video nothing
would have ever happened
i'm going to remind myself you started
something you taught
someone a lesson and now the lawyer for
mimi groves is calling out the
university of
it tennessee give her a meaningful
investigation
which would have revealed that this
happened years ago would have revealed
the context
of it they hurriedly made a decision
and forced her out and that sets a bad
example of course it's horribly unfair
and devastating to her and to her family
and it's not the job that an educational
institution should be doing
so jason i want to start with you should
mimi groves be held accountable for
something she said at age 15.
i i think that's the problem lisa i i
like what they're actually doing in
europe where you have the right to be
forgotten
you know we excuse a lot as minors and
if you do something stupid
as a minor i mean who among us that
doesn't have some sort of
something stupid we said or did or
something else that's why we're a minor
and so
that you should be able to be forgotten
for that i think legislation and dealing
with social media companies
is going to have to change long term
because you're exchanging
your access to who you are where you're
doing
doing going what social media you're
using
and these social media companies then
can go and monetize that
but if you suddenly break that contract
and say i don't want to do that anymore
you
i think have the right to be forgotten
certainly when you're 15 years old
this poor young woman i put it in
context
made a mistake she apologized for it but
she's got to be able to move on with her
life
well and lawrence what do you what kind
of message well first of all i went to
the university of tennessee so i'm
ashamed of their actions here but what
message do you think they're sending
future applicants um
i i really hate to play the race card on
this but as the black
member on this panel this is ridiculous
is this where we're at in society we
have real issues
that are affecting black america you got
the state abusing these powers in some
communities you got redlining still
happen you got an education system
that continues to put us in zip codes
that they know is failing
you have a a planned parenthood that
literally put their
abortion facilities in in our
communities to kill us
and this the 15 year old white girl is
who we go after it is shameful
what we choose to cover as a news media
the fact that this is a national media
story
the fact that this is a topic on this
show today it is shameful
because they really don't care about us
i would love to give some type of
political response to this
but this story lacks humanity you know
back home i'm from texas in the south
and i remember having a race uh racist
encounter with one of my former
teammates
and you know i don't promote violence
but we had a little scuffle on the
playground
and after that we end up becoming
friends
because we dealt with it and then we got
over it
they didn't give this girl any room to
deal with
her problem they decided to make this a
national story
and destroy the rest of her life i'm not
saying that she's innocent
or she there shouldn't be any
consequences but the way that they
handle this
is shameful and i guarantee you there's
a lot of yearbooks and a lot of
videotapes of
stuff that other people have done do
y'all really want to start doing this
because it won't be pretty
well and marie about that and we just
heard from lawrence criticism of the
media
and the new york times for running the
story should they have
should they have ran it well i actually
think that the new york times story
in some respects cast her in quite a
sympathetic light i think
you came away from reading that story
thinking
wow should something she had said when
she was 15 something horrific that she
never should have said
should that have impacted her life in
the way it did her life is not ruined
she can apply to another college and i'm
sure she will get in but i actually
think the story was fairly
was fairly balanced and it raised a lot
of complicated questions
i would also say that for people who say
well why should this girl's
life be changed for something she did
when she was 15 why shouldn't she be
giving the benefit of the doubt
we've heard from some black activists
who have said
you know there are a ton of young black
men who are never given the benefit of
the doubt who do things when they are
minors who because of the criminal
justice system
are locked up in jail or even worse
killed by police or are injured by
police so i think that there are a lot
of activists who would say
yes we feel bad for this young woman but
there are a lot of young black men who
are never given the benefit of the doubt
and never given a chance
because their lives are taken from them
uh because
of things they did as miners
back in here and i'll get to use it as a
shield to defend this story
because things happen as i just listed
out to black folks
every single day instead of focusing on
those
issues and making it right we target
other groups of people
that's not right and the fact that still
even marie just used us as a shield well
this is what the activists said so that
must make it right
i didn't use it as a shield lawrence i
was quoting what people have said i also
said it was
complicated i wasn't blaming her
i want to get i want to get emily in
here before we've got to go because
we're
running out of time here you know emily
she's obviously retained
an attorney uh does she have any legal
recourse
uh sure she does i mean we can have an
injunctive action
taken by the university which
essentially means opening up her spot
back up
i would like to say that baked into the
fabric of how we operate as americans
is the concept of rehabilitation and
that's why in law
we have end dates to sentences it's why
we have restitution
and recompense and the opportunity to
cure and that's why the punishment
should fit the crime
and why essentially there are
consequences for behavior and then it's
over and done with
i don't understand the people to marie's
point who advocate
for criminal justice reform and also
advocate for lifelong cancer culture
there's a condemnation of to civic death
that's going on for these people exactly
to jason's point of minors
and yes there should be the a different
approach to social media ownership that
europe takes versus us
i wholeheartedly agree with and to back
to the university for a second the fact
that it's a public institution
so the tax dollars from this poor girl's
family that goes to pay for it
is how exactly they can essentially
ignore her first amendment rights deny
her admission on a character basis
i could see the squad doing that the
cheerleading squad but for them to do
that
that's this kind of cancel culture
ridiculousness um
being manifested in these huge public
institutions
well and to marie's point real quick
before we have to go you know president
trump was the one that got criminal
justice reform when obama did not but
moving on